all right speaker pelosi tonight is
actually berating the media mob uh
forget this
not doing enough to help sell the
democrats extreme green new deal agenda
you can't make this up take a look
do you think you need to do a better job
at messaging and going forward how do
you sell this if ultimately well i think
you all could do a better job of selling
it to be very frank with you because
every time i come here i go through the
list
family medical leave climate
the issues that are in there and um but
it is true it is hard to break through
when you have such a comprehensive
package
i think you all could do a better job
selling it that would be the media
they're paid propagandists with reaction
fox news contributor media columnist his
own right for the hill i think he should
have his own show on media joe conch is
with us uh you should all do a better
job of selling our new green deal
socialism
i can't understand why you're not doing
a good enough job selling it for us
that already wins line of the week we're
not even halfway through
you should be selling this for us better
sean i have expected her to start
lecturing that coffee is for closers and
abc always be closing now look it
provides a crystal clear glimpse into
how democrats expect the media to sell
they as lawmakers should be selling but
this can't be sold it's like selling
advanced playoff tickets for the new
york jets it can't be done in this
spending bill's case it's because the
math sorry jet fans has never remotely
added up and and repeating this line
sean over and over again i know sorry
look look it's a transition year but can
you say i like the quarterback but but
here pelosi and the president and the
press secretary keep saying this over
and over again that trillions in new
spending will cost the american taxpayer
0.0 dollars it will also reduce taxes
and the debt it's a bold-faced lie it's
insulting to anybody's intelligence and
pelosi expects reporters to tell that
even the friendliest of press members
think that's crazy jen saki said the
president wants to make fundamental
changes to our economy and he feels like
coming out of the pandemic is the exact
same time to do it we can't afford the
trillions of dollars it's impossible nor
will any of their promises be fulfilled
joe
i'd love to see one of the reporters
there say how do you think we should
rebuild the economy in the manner that
you'd like to by spending trillions of
new dollars right on top of the
trillions that we've already spent on
covet and cover-related programs by the
way when inflation is at a 30-year high
i'm pretty sure that will cause more
inflation stagflation and a lot of
myriad of other problems but we don't
seem to be getting that question for
some reason i'd like to see that asked
yeah that's why you deserve your own
show because you're like standing apart
you're not part of the the twitter blue
checkmark media cult
that's actually a good thing i wanted
the bachelor i wanted the bachelor to
give the jesse palmer the the former
backup quarterback for the giants that's
all i wanted as a show you can't save
yourself sean it's not going well hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else